he won't give you
a price cap on commercial
power supplies won't remove domestic cap
how many companies do you expect to go
bust this winter
that is a really difficult question
answer to answer i know it sounds like
obfuscation when i say this but honestly
we don't know
um what we do know is we are expecting
other companies to fail on the on the
retail side and of course that does
eventually mean costs for customers i
think the secretary of state is right
that the priority right now is to make
sure people have
a continued supply through the winter
but on the other side of this i think we
do have to ask ourselves some questions
about why our retail sector was so
fragile
when you say uh fragile um
how would you uh assess that fragility
in terms of the winter coming
do you think we aren't going to run out
of gas or have to ration
in terms of security of supply
we also agree that um you know we're
lucky in the uk we've got a diverse
range
of energy sources in the uk on the
electricity generation side you know
renewables nuclear storage
interconnection and gas and as the
secretary of state says
not all of our gas comes from russia
we've got nausea oil and gas too so
in terms of the system
even though the margin is tighter than
in previous years the system operator is
telling us that they think that system
security is fine
the issue is of course the cost and then
what that does to the businesses who are
having to buy gas at that price so
businesses are particularly exposed like
you know energy intensive users and some
of our generators and then our retailers
because of the way that they hedge the
market
you know that's the consequence here
well one of the consequences to return
to my first question
is that some are going to go out of
business aren't they
we are expecting more retailers to go
out of business yes this winter so we
had
you know around 50 suppliers when they
started and we're expecting to see
more leave the market as the secretary
of state says we have had a process of
consolidation we have had retailers
leaving the market in previous years
the issue is how many are failing at
once and
whether or not our mechanisms which are
in place to look after customers when
that happens up for that many failures
in one go
and of course then what that means for
retail on the other side of this and in
the spring or when prices return to
normal
well we know that um there is the system
the supply of last resort and all of
that
and let's say that will protect the
domestic
customer
what is going to be the situation for
the commercial and industrial user
are we
going to see rationing
of power supplies to
industries like chemicals or paper
production manufacturing or or
indeed
medicine uh and so on is that is that a
possibility this winter
i think if we're learning anything
through this you know crisis on gas
prices it's how important energy is the
you know the functioning of the rest of
the economy
okay i don't actually know what the
consequences for commercial users will
be though they are more exposed to the
prices where they have to
buy energy at the price we're seeing on
the market and the same for some of our
generators what i will tell you is our
members are increasingly worried about
those customers and on top of that i
think it's less clear what will happen
to business customers and the last thing
to say on this is of course when we say
commercial customers is actually quite a
big range that's everything from you
know your local corner shop through to
as you say that the manufacturers of
steel so i think it's right that the
secretary of state is talking to the
energy intensive users but we would also
like to see a bit of a focus on
commercial customers as a whole and
thinking imaginatively about each kind
of commercial customer and what sort of
support they might need but yes of
course we're worried
what are the options for support for let
us say
retail or hospitality
is it just more money
or is it the
commercial price cap
yeah there's a range of things we can do
but as you said uh i heard the the talk
of the commercial price cap um i think
we're only just so as this crisis has
rolled through we've had different
concerns at different points and so you
know originally we were worried about
security supply that looks like it's all
right for the system we obviously
started to worry and continue to be
worried about our retail and our
domestic customers and vulnerable people
and how we support them
now i'm starting to hear concern about
commercial customers in particular and
the energy intensive users so this is a
debate that started over the last few
days there's a range of options on the
table i don't think it would be
appropriate to comment on which one at
this stage but suffice to say you know
that there may need to be an
intervention there have been
interventions in other markets
what sort of intervention what does an
intervention look like here
they've been they've been all kinds of
things so you know
different markets have done it
differently they've they've looked after
their retailers they've they've you know
done extra support for their energy
intensive users or
commercial customers or generators so
there's a whole range of things
depending on the structure of your
energy market now for for us in the
energy industry the thing that we're
still very very worried about is is
domestic retail i think that's where
we'll see more failures in the coming
weeks and and then what we do about the
costs of that for
individual consumers you know for you
and me and paying our bills and for
vulnerable people
then there's a separate conversation to
be had about energy intensive uses and
other businesses that are exposed in
particular to the high prices
it's not my job to to solve that problem
for government we're a regulated market
you know if we need additional support
you know the regulator and the
government will have to step in but we
are
happy to be in those conversations and
we definitely need to keep talking
because this is not over yet
okay i just want to clarify the business
secretary uh quasi quoting um said in an
interview with conservative home that
the economy is in a transitional stage
the words tough it out were put to him
by the interview uh it wasn't his phrase
um but
i do think that uh there is a sense
somewhere here that actually the
government doesn't have a very specific
thing they want to put forward but they
hope that in a way it will
uh it will be okay are you satisfied
that you're getting
uh enough if you like direct
action or activity from the government
we'll say that this government and
particularly the secretary of state has
been very good at engaging with industry
and trying to understand the issues
what's what's not clear is you know when
and if they need to act whether they can
do that in terms of the market
look you know the the private sector
does some you know real good in this
country we've invested billions of
pounds in transforming the energy system
we're building the offshore wind fleet
in partnership with government you know
there's
we don't need
necessarily the government to run these
markets however it's a regulated
industry you know we it's a public
utility
we provide an essential service to the
economy as well as doing things like
delivering on the government's net zero
commitment so there's no way that we can
do this entirely on our own that said
you know the
the wait and see approach and targeting
the intervention correctly and doing the
right thing at the right time is not
wrong we just need to know that if there
is a need to act that we'll be able to
do that rapidly and and that's that's
the piece to focus on is the government
preparing for a plan b or a plan c if
the
wait and see approach doesn't work out
all right just very quickly if i may ask
um
you're not going to get a commercial
price cap would you
want the price cap level which is about
12.77 per therm uh uh now to rise and if
so
how far
really challenging environment for
industry so the the retailers as a whole
have been making a negative margin for
the last couple of years and that's not
just
down to the price cut that's the
function of the retail market as a whole
the secretary of state and the
energy regulator has committed to
looking at that on the other side of
this crisis and we would really welcome
that we think we have to learn some
lessons of what we're experiencing right
now for retail that said
everyone in the industry recognizes that
at the moment the price cap is
protecting consumers from these really
high prices so
you know we're not asking for it to be
removed
if the price cap stays in the long run
we are going to have to look at the
methodology though because one of the
things about the price cap is it doesn't
move in line with these rapidly changing
prices so
the industry is currently in a situation
where it's setting prices based on
um prices from months ago it's not
really live enough to reflect current
market conditions so
the price cap for now we're saying
should stay to protect consumers in the
long run it's very clear we need to look
at our retail market from top to bottom
and if the price cap stays we need to
look at the methodology for sure